hola de nuevo bueno pensé en hacer
algunos algunos ejemplos de con el
método de cociente o división parcial
largo entonces
vamos a hacer un ejemplo qué te parece
este número espeluznante tal vez te
asuste pero pero está fácil supongamos
que 291 divide a este número en el cual
simplemente estoy y aventando números
pero bueno veamos que ese es 9 millones
873 mil 952 y bueno analicemos esto
tenemos que 291 por 1s ya lo sabemos es
esta sencillo 291 por uno es igual a 291
y 291 por 10 es igual a 2.910 ahora como
en el vídeo anterior vamos a ver que hay
entre esos dos valores entonces pongamos
algún número aquí que nos pueda ayudar a
aproximarnos a la cantidad de veces que
291 cabe en este número super mega
alocado
qué te parece si lo intentamos con tres
o seis y dos y siete bueno el tres suena
bien cierto entonces 291 por tres puedo
hacerlo acá abajo para no equivocarme
entonces 291 por tres sabemos que tres
por uno es igual a tres 3 por 9 es igual
a 27 y 3 por 2 es igual a 6 más 2 es
igual a 8 entonces tenemos 873 como
resultado y b de hecho esta es el número
ahí no sé es casualidades de la vida yo
creo porque pero no es relevante así que
no es relevante para el resultado ahora
vamos a intentarlo también con el número
6 entonces vamos a multiplicar 291 por 6
eso que nos da será de hecho este
resultado multiplicado por dos cierto
pero pero lo voy a hacer completo
entonces 291 por 6 1 por 6 es igual a 6
9 por 6 es igual a 54 y 2 por 6 es igual
a 12 5 es igual a 17 por lo tanto el
resultado aquí es 1000
746 y tal vez te preguntes yo no
entiendo por qué hizo todo eso por qué
por qué por qué pero solamente lo hice o
lo estoy utilizando como herramienta de
aproximación para averiguar cuántas
veces cabe el 291 en ese número gigante
a primero que todo lo que vamos a hacer
es veamos a cuántas veces cabe 291 en
nueve millones a ver veamos 291 por tres
es igual a 873 y queremos un montón de
ceros después de los 873 ahora escojo
este número porque este dígito está está
cercano a 9 aunque no es 9 es menor pero
es el más cercano así que 873 y tendré
unos 234 ceros después del número 291
por 3 es igual a 873 pero tengo que
multiplicarlo por 3 y 4 ceros ajá es
decir 30 mil así que tengo que
multiplicar 291 por 30.000 y me va a dar
esa respuesta que es 8 millones
cientos 30 mil y después como en todas
las divisiones vamos a restar restamos
estos números 2 - 0 es igual a 0 después
5 937 3 es igual a 4 8 7 es igual a 1 y
9 menos 8 es igual a 1 nos queda
entonces un millón 143 mil 952 entonces
cuál de estos números nos acerca am no
podemos usar este número en 1746 porque
ese s será demasiado grande ajá qué te
parece 873 otra vez pero 873.000 ajá
873.000 y tenemos esto esto es este 3
con tres ceros
ajá 12 30 así que 291 por 3 es igual a
873 y 291 por 3000 es igual a 873.000 lo
escribiré aquí mejor porque creo que no
está del todo del todo claro pero ahí
está esto es 3000 por 291
restamos vamos a restar estos dos
valores ajá así que pongo esta línea y 2
- 0 es igual a 25 menos 0 es igual a 59
- 0 es igual a 93 menos 3 es igual a 0 y
ahora 4 -7 veamos aquí debemos pedir
prestado entonces lo que vamos a hacer
es le pido prestado al 1 ajá esto se
hace esto se hace 11 y después le pido
prestado al 11 a esto se vuelve 10 ahora
esto se vuelve un 14 y 14 menos 7 es
igual a 7 10 menos 8 es igual a 2 nos
queda 270 mil 952 y ok bien que es lo
más cercano a eso parece que 291 por 6
si restamos aquí 17 46 y agregó aquí dos
ceros esto es lo mismo que multiplicar
por 600 ajá
una vez más ese mundo resta voy a restar
esto y tenemos que 2 - 0 eso es igual a
2 bajan 2 - 0 igual a 250 es igual a 5
96 es igual a 3 ahora 0 - 4 aquí
nuevamente tenemos que pedir prestado
esto se vuelve un 6 y esto es ahora un
10 10 menos 4 es igual a 6 aquí el 6 es
menor que el 7 entonces otra vez pedimos
prestado y esto se hace 16 menos 7 es
igual hay varios vídeos en los que
enseñó cómo pedir prestado y hacer este
tipo de restas pero bueno 16 menos 7 es
igual a 9 nos quedan 96 1352 así que
otra vez otra vez parece que 873 hace el
truco lo pongo aquí y agregó dos ceros
estoy multiplicando 291 por 300 ajá
ahora hago
arresta otra vez vamos a hacer esta
resta nos queda 2 - 0 es igual a 250
esto se hace 16 esto se hace 8 16
7 es igual a 9 y tenemos tenemos que
acercarnos ahora 9.052 otra vez parece
que este este número está súper bien en
873 hace el truco nuevamente pongo este
número con un 0 estamos multiplicando
291 por 30 y restamos 2 - 0 es igual a
25 menos 3 es igual a 2 90 menos 87 es
igual a 3 y creo que ya tienes la idea
general de esto nos va a quedar 322
debemos aproximarnos a ese número a 322
y parece que 291 se acerca bastante así
que simplemente ponemos 291 aquí hacemos
la resta y nos queda un residuo de 31
291 ya no cabe en 31 así que 31 es
nuestro residuo pero
es el resultado general 291 cuántas
veces cupo en 9 millones 873 mil 952
simplemente hay que sumar todos estos
valores y a ver veamos esto sería igual
a 33 mil 931 ajá ese es el resultado es
el resultado simplemente sumas esos lo
puedes hacer en tu cabeza
el resultado es 33 mil 931 espero no
haber hecho alguna equivocación pero esa
es la idea general de cómo se hace esto
espero te haya gustado y espero se haya
entendido nos vemos pronto
bye